Hi! This is Sydney Sweeney.
I am here on the Sony backlot,
and I'm going to take you
into stage 14
and show you where we film
Euphoria.
♪ (MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Well, hello!
Welcome to the Euphoria
base camp.
-Say hello.
-Hey!
SYDNEY SWEENEY: We're doing
a base camp tour.
Oh!
This is the hair and makeup
where everything happens.
You can see all the pictures
of different makeup looks
that we've done.
-(POLICE SIRENS WAILING)
-Cops are after us.
(GIGGLING)
Do you wanna take 'em
to the set?
Cool.
You were honestly made for this.
(CHUCKLES)
You need to own one of these.
SWEENEY:
They're working right now.
So literally, it's just like...
facades. It's crazy.
Usually we come here
and everything's already done...
-ALEXA DEMIE:  Set up and--
-Yeah.
Wait, let's see.
This is the map.
-Dressing room.
-DEMIE: Uh...
Okay, so this is what
they're building.
Yeah. That's so cool.
Can we take them
to the other stage?
-Ooh, we got our cart over here.
-Wrong cart.
Nope. Wrong cart! (CHUCKLES)
Going to this cart over here.
-Hey, Syd. I got you...
-(GASPS)
-They're warm.
-Cookies!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
SWEENEY: Going on in!
We're filming episode seven
and eight right now.
Filming school stuff.
-What?!
-Oh, my God. Hi!
-Well, hello!
-What are you doing here?
-What are you doing here? Oh!
-Get in here.
-Let's go!
(LAUGHTER)
This is our school!
And here, we have cast holding
right now but sometimes,
it is set as a classroom.
-There's cameras on both sides.
-It's on both sides?
So it's recording here
and a camera here.
-What? (LAUGHS)
-The whole time?
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Welcome to our school dance!
There's 3,000 stars up there.
Take them into the balloon hall!
This is the balloon hall.
Do you guys wanna pose for a--
a portrait? Click!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
You will see tons of people
dancing here, music.
(CHATTERING)
Bye for now!
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪